the leader of the lib dems ed davey is
with us now do you agree with uh secure
stamina there who says that the prime
minister was treating people as mugs
i do
i think the prime minister has knowingly
lied to parliament
time and time again and he did break the
rules very clear from sue grey's report
which i thought was extremely a dummy
indictment of the prime minister uh that
there were wrongdoings going on in part
in number 10. and you know i think it's
now the conservative mp's job to act
they have the power they can write the
letters to sir graeme brady and get a
vote of no confidence in the prime
minister
i think it's their patriotic duty
frankly
our country's got huge problems energy
bills heating bills cost living crisis
the problems in the ukraine which we
know about the pandemic still
we have a prime minister who can't
address those because he's got this huge
cloud over his over his head and it's
distracting him so i think conservative
mps
recognizing that must get rid of him
uh but it's up to them um and uh if they
don't you're just shouting in the wind
well i don't think that's the case um i
think that the british people are
registering their views we've seen an
opinion poll last night saying nearly
two-thirds think he should resign and if
conservative mps won't uh take action
what about conservative councillors i'd
like to see conservative councillors and
certified council candidates registering
the voters disapproval by by resigning
from the conservative party not standing
at the local elections because if they
don't voters will say to them what did
you do
just as they'll say that to conservative
mps so this is a crisis in the
conservative party now they're allowing
a man who we know is a law breaker we
know is dishonest to continue in this
job when we have huge problems in our
country so that's why it's their
patriotic duty of tory and peace to act
so you're calling on grassroots
conservatives to remove the prime
minister if the backbenchers don't want
to well they haven't the power to remove
him
they're contacting their uh
their mp they they all need to i think
uh register their dissatisfaction i've
seen a number of programs on sky on on
other channels where you've interviewed
conservative party members who don't
look happy at all
the opinion poll last night showed that
nearly half of conservative voters want
the prime minister resign this is
unprecedented territory
and so you know i i i i think if they
don't right if he stays he will be
investigated by the police there'll be
an interview he'll have legal advice
well he if there's a police
investigation i think it's quite likely
that he will be interested he said he
didn't know there were parties he may
not be interviewed he may have a couple
of emails that he needs to answer while
he goes about the uh business uh of
power i i i think that's highly unlikely
uh i i think the met police will have to
interview him and i think he'll have to
take legal advice so i've written to the
treasury solicitor today who governs
these matters and i've said i don't
believe the taxpayers should be paying
the prime minister's legal bills
and i think he should pay personally he
was a personal parties including one in
his own flat that he'd be investigated
for it's not right for the taxpayer to
pick up the prime minister's legal bills
um it is of course up to the police
where they go next and we're just gonna
have to wait for their report you've
been less than complimentary about the
police so far
yeah i wrote to chris dick they met
police commissioner a few weeks ago and
i asked her she would investigate and
she chose not to the right police line
back then
uh was that they weren't going to
investigate retrospective offences they
then changed that position said they
might investigate but they wait for the
sue gray report then they changed their
mind again and said they would
investigate but sue gray's report could
be published and then they changed their
mind for a fourth time and said they're
going to investigate but sue gray
couldn't publish her reporting in full
and when you see the mech commissioner
new scotland yard changing their mind
four times it does not look good now
it's either incompetence that's probably
probably what this real story is or it's
really really disturbing in what way
well there's a perception of some sort
of stitch up and you know rank and fire
police officers who i completely support
they put their lives on the line for the
safety of hers every day
they need to ensure that the the trust
and confidence of the public is in them
we
we police
by uh community consent a public consent
um and if the met commission if the high
command is undermining that by
perception that they're not uh treating
everyone the same and that's very
damaging for police it's damaging for
our democracy so i stand by what i said
i really hope the mec can explain
themselves far more if it has been
incompetent if they kept changing their
mind please explain it to us do you
think he was a stitcher
i don't know i don't have the the
evidence what i'm saying is that it the
perception of stitch up is damaging and
they have to clear it up so i would have
said that the sue grey report should be
published in full and if it can't be i
want a detailed explanation from that
police we got some explanation yesterday
to be fair to new scotland yard rather
late in the day um but i don't think it
was as substantive as it needs to be you
know i think people want this uh report
published in full the prime minister
initially yesterday said he was going to
not publish it in full he was very very
ambiguous about that eventually he was
forced to say he would publish it in
full and i hope the met police will back
that up crime in london is high um crime
across the country despite what the
prime minister said he said it was a 14
cut it's actually a 14
increase according um to the shadow home
secretary the police are very busy doing
other stuff should they really be
worried about peanuts and crisps and um
warm white wine in the garden of number
ten it's not about uh the peanuts and
crips it's about making sure the rules
apply equally to everybody
the police were issuing uh thousands of
notices uh
to to people across the country and
cooling in london um and lots of people
got fined and lots of people were told
off and they're looking at the prime
minister and saying okay we we took our
punishment why can't he um what i think
should happen in the police more
generally tackling crime if that's that
that's a concern really is we need more
police officers but actually if you look
at what boris johnson promised he
promised there'd be 20 000 extra police
officers but they're behind their
schedule they're not recruiting anywhere
near fast enough what liberal democrats
want we do want a lot more community
police in our constituencies and
communities across london and across the
country but the prime minister and the
conservative government are failing to
deliver on their own promises on police
officers to replace the 21 000 that we
lost just to just to clarify that uh
yeah no you're absolutely right um and
as far as ian blackford is concerned
should he have um
stormed out last night yesterday
well i i thought it looked a little
childish i have to sell you i mean uh
you know he looked round to his uh back
benches when he was putting on that it's
like pantomime he was because he was
smiling
so serious face of the camera smiles to
his about benches it didn't look like it
was fabricated so while you know i i've
said to you today that i thought the
prime minister has lied to parliament um
we have to have rules in parliament and
the speaker was right to uphold those
rules what was the atmosphere like in
the house yesterday
it was quite febrile
um i think a real
sense on the opposition that the prime
minister should go
and in the conservative adventures that
was really interesting i was looking at
their body language and their their
their facial uh positions and they
they look unhappy
um they didn't look like they were
hugely in support of the prime minister
and while there was a lot of cheering it
was coming from just a few people
so um although we hear reports that this
meeting last night this private meeting
that they were supportive of him i think
many of them are questioning and you did
hear people andrew mitchell saying he
lost the confidence and theresa may um
she didn't actually send out she said
that well we know what she said um but
as far as body language is concerned
we've actually got a body language
expert on coming up so it'd be
interesting to see what they make of it
but do you have some sympathy with the
front bench
the conservative from bench no because
they're sticking by the prime minister
it should be their job
no no their job is to serve the country
and the national interest is not being
served by uh people who
stand by this prime minister he has
broken the rules he's broken the
ministerial code it's pretty clear from
sue gray's report i mean i was i had
expected sue grey's report to be much
milder and i thought it might even be a
little bit of a whitewash but even
within the restriction to severe
limitations imposed on her she made some
extremely damning findings
and for cabinet ministers to stand by a
prime minister who's has really been
found out i don't think it's good enough
particularly when our country faces such
crisis and particularly the uh the cost
of living crisis we need someone who's
got credibility the prime minister
doesn't he's going to be a joke when he
uh tries to help out in ukraine and
russia no one's going to take him
seriously there he needs to go in the
national interest the tory mps needs to
do their patriotic duty okay debbie it's
always a pleasure thank you very much
indeed for joining us thank you